more clark county school district
students prepare to go back to the
classroom this week
it's the final wave of students
transitioning to in-person learning
after spring break
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in the newsroom tonight
with more on the adjustments
kristin sasha tuesday is when grades 4 5
7 8 10 and 11 finally return following a
year of distance education
they'll join their peers who came back
last month to start hybrid learning
that's when students take classes two
days in person
and then online remotely the other part
of the week but
elementary schools get ready for another
big adjustment in their schedule
we're really excited to get more kids
back
eager and enthusiastic gerheim
elementary school principal ryan
lewis prepares to welcome all students
back on campus the big challenge of
april 6th is really
just the masses again fourth and fifth
graders will join pre-kindergarten to
third grade students who chose to come
back last month
but that's not the only shift
all elementary schools will start
in-person learning
five days a week as well as increase
classroom capacity up to 75 percent
the state allows this change after a
school completes 20 days of some form of
in-person instruction
we're going to make the best of it vicki
criedel though questions the overall
transition
so far in the district there's different
concerns from the teachers pretty much
the national education association of
southern nevada president tells me
some staff do not maintain social
distancing i heard stories of
teachers saying that they go into their
school and there's groups of teachers
sitting
eating together she and the clark county
education association acknowledge
specialists who teach classes like art
music and pe
also raise concerns to the unions about
the current schedule they're actually
being put at
more risk than other classroom teachers
because they have to enter multiple
classrooms we made it to where the
memorandum of agreement was that schools
can come up with unique
situations for their buildings
situations presenting possible strategic
issues
but lewis and others prepare to stay
flexible we're doing our best
middle and high schools plan to continue
hybrid learning for the remainder of the
school year
full-time distance education remains an
option for families
reporting live in the newsroom kristin
drummond 8 news now